redux a single source of truth for all
the data in your javascript application
modern web applications are represented
as a complex tree of components
components that constantly produce and
share data called state and when state
is decentralized it can become difficult
to understand and test redux is both a
pattern and library that helps
developers implement complex state
management requirements at scale it was
created by dan abramov and andrew clark
at facebook and is one of the most loved
and hated libraries in the react
ecosystem it relies on a single
immutable object to store all of the
application state kind of like a
client-side database to change the state
like when a button is clicked an action
will be dispatched which has a name like
an event and a payload with the data
that it wants to change remember the
store is immutable so to change the
state of the application an entirely new
object is created by passing the current
state and the action payload into a
reducer function which returns a new
object with the entire application state
the end result is a one-way data flow
that is predictable and testable and it
also opens the door to awesome dev tools
that allow you to time travel through
your application's data but it comes at
a cost of additional boilerplate code
that might add too much complexity to a
smaller project to get started create a
react app with your favorite tool then
install the redux toolkit first use
configure store to set up the global
store object which will register any
reducers defined elsewhere in the code
then provider will make its data
accessible to the entire component tree
next create a slice like pizza to
represent some data in the store it
should have a unique name and initial
state but most importantly it contains a
collection of reducers which are
functions that take the old state and an
action then define the logic required to
change the state redux toolkit will
automatically generate actions that
correspond to the names of these reducer
functions we can export them then put
them to use in an actual ui component
the beauty of redux is that we can
select data anywhere in the application
without the need for context or prop
drilling instead we can grab any
reactive value or slice in the store
with the use selector hook now to change
the application's data an action needs
to be dispatched to the store that can
be accomplished with the use dispatch
hook which might send an action name and
data payload on a normal browser event
like a button click now serve the
application and install the redux
devtools browser extension unlike a
normal project you're able to inspect
and debug the entire timeline of actions
and state changes in your application
this has been redux in 100 seconds
upgrade to fireship pro if you want to
learn all kinds of other react concepts
in a format like this thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one